quatrième point que je tenais à faire
avec vous en ce vendredi sur la
situation dans le département de la
vienne en lien avec la crise sanitaire
tout d'abord vous dire que la
distribution de masques continue nous en
sommes à plus de 140 mille masques
aujourd'hui distribués et nous allons
continuer la semaine prochaine au fur à
mesure de la réception de nos commandes
nous restons très attentifs sur la
situation dans les ehpad et nous allons
proposer très prochainement en lien avec
notre laboratoire interdépartemental
calice que préside sybille pecriaux des
tests covit 19 à destination des
résidents mais également des personnels
qui accompagne ses résidents nous
restons également mobilisés pour veiller
à ce qu'un centre de services
fonctionnent de nouveau très
prochainement je pense notamment à la
poste il est indispensable que ses
membres de bureaux de poste puis serait
ouvrir très prochainement sur les
territoires je sais combien ce service
est indispensable notamment en milieu
rural
nos services sont évidemment mobilisé à
la fois je pense aux routes les
fauchages vont bientôt reprendre le long
des routes départementales
et puis les travaux du numérique vont
également reprendre on voit bien comment
le déploiement de la fibre est un enjeu
essentiel à la fois en aménagement du
territoire mais également aujourd'hui
comment il est indispensable au titre de
la formation s'adresse d'ailleurs vifs
remerciements à l'ensemble des
enseignants qui accompagne aujourd'hui
nos élèves leurs élèves dans leur
travail à domicile
nous serons prêts quant à nous pour la
réouverture des collèges je l'espère le
plus tôt possible pour qu'il puisse
fonctionner à accueillir de nouveau les
élèves courant du mois de mai et puis
nous allons réfléchir accompagné en lien
avec la direction académique ses élèves
pour éviter qu un décrochage scolaire
puisse est la conséquence de cette crise
sanitaire
je vous souhaite en cette veille de
week-end de pâques de passer de bonnes
fêtes pascales
mais surtout prenez soin de vous